and then we called the church and we're
like hey can you marry us and they're
like are you sure this is really fast
with Layla I had just gotten out of Like
A Five-Year Engagement and so I was just
not really even digging marriage in
general we started hanging out and the
next day I woke up and was like Hey I'm
working all day if you want to like work
next to me cut this guy's odd and so we
pretty much hung out every day after
that nine-ish months in the team started
getting worried because the companies
were really fast what happens if you
guys break up and I was like we're not
gonna break up it's fine like why would
we break up they were like that's not
good enough for us and so I went to her
and I was like I think we should get
married and she said yeah that sounds
good then we went to the store got a
ring and then came back like 45 minutes
later and then we called the church and
we're like hey can you marry us six days
later we got married in the back of a
church with no one there and then we
told our friends and family after we got
married hey by the way we got engaged
and they were like hey that's so amazing
and we also got married and then they
were horrified